At this point, the character of
our discussion of computability
is going to change significantly.
We've established the key
properties of Turing machines.
That they can do anything
we mean by computation,
and that we can pass a description of
a Turing machine to a Turing machine
as input for it to simulate.
With those points established, we won't
need to talk about the specifics of
Turing machines much anymore.
There will be little about tapes, or
states, transitions, or head positions.
Instead, we'll think about
computation at a very high level.
Trusting that if we really had to,
we could write out
the Turing machine to do it.
If we need to write out code,
we'll do so
mostly in pseudocode or with pictures.
What is there left to talk about?
Well remember from the very first
lesson that we argued that not
all functions are computable or
as we later said not all languages
can be decided by Turing machines.
We're now in a good position to talk
about some of these undecidable
languages.
We had to wait until we established
the universality of Turing machines.
Because these languages
are going to consist of strings
that encode Turing machines.
The rest of the lesson we'll review
the definitions of recognizability and
decidability and then we'll talk
about the positive side of the story.
The languages about Turing machines
that we can decide or recognize.
As we'll see later,
there are plenty that we can't.